i remember uh you know one of my
teachers saying that he was in a
in a meeting with some of the sheikhs
and one of the students of knowledge
asked
kind of like in a shy way uh excuse me
my uncle you know he was egyptian
he said can we like
you know lick it like is it permissible
[Music]
[Music]
if both of them have responsibilities or
roles
it is irrational to expect or demand
that they fulfill something which allah
himself is not made obligatory
this whole thing about uh i still want
him to do a little bit of
dishes or just do a little bit of the
choice
if he does it he does it if he doesn't
he doesn't but you cannot expect that
similarly if a woman wants to work
cool you know women can work i'm not
against that she wants to go to school
cool
but you cannot expect her to make money
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dona the three muslims featuring our
very special guest
who might as well be part of the three
muslims now we might as well change
the four muslims
so today we are joined for episode six
of the intimacy series
a lot of people have been waiting we
left them last episode with uh
you know on a high we kind of teased
them
we left them with so today it's gonna be
a little bit more of uh the actual
intimacy what goes down i'm sure
everyone that started episode one
this is the episode they've been waiting
for this is the moment
that they've been waiting for what do
you have to say
i'm ready let's go you ready we don't we
don't have uh
the king of intimacy today if you guys
made it for last episode he's
[Music]
allah to give us beneficial knowledge
and indeed
intimacy is part of beneficial knowledge
the prophet saw sallam
he said to the sahaba he said that if
you are intimate with your wife
allah will give you reward so they were
shocked
right you could probably expect their
mindset was kind of like
what we find sometimes in some of the
muslims today where like
you know they would think that in faith
and the the the sphere of religion or
faith right that these things wouldn't
be discussed so the prophet sallam
responded to them
and he said would you not be punished by
allah if you were to do it in
haram or in the wrong way
and so on they said yes ya rasulullah of
course or message of allah
so he said that's why allah when you do
it in the right way or in halal you get
you get basically rewarded by it okay
so imagine i mean you could say
i don't want to be so logical here but
you could say more intimacy more
reward isn't it right so that's
something that we have to keep in mind
and the prophet salallahu he
did say in a very famous hadith that i
will be proud of my ummah
because of their numbers on the day of
judgement
okay because they're numbers i mean you
don't get numbers by
doing nothing i mean numbers means
procreation right
oh okay okay you have to be intimate and
you cannot be intimate unless you are
intimate
and i think last time we talked right
the woman
subhanallah it's quite shocking that a
lot of men and
many many women do not understand their
body
and the way their body works so a woman
will release an
usually one egg some women release two
eggs
per month okay one and that egg has
about
24 hours to 48 hours
to be basically uh uh
to basically uh to the walls yeah
exactly yeah and to be fertilized by the
sperm
okay now what happens is so it's
basically talking about
one to two days add about three days if
you've been intimate and
sperm will live within the female
so sperm will be there active for about
three days
so technically speaking a woman
could get pregnant only about
five days in 30 days
okay or out of 30 days that's it and
most people don't sit around
calculating when you're the most fertile
i mean now they have these applications
and whatnot but in general i mean you
know you're not going to calculate right
so
to increase the chance of you know
having children
you know fulfilling the hadith of the
prophet it means you really have to be
busy pretty much
you know every day and sometimes a few
times a day now i know some people get
shocked and whatnot but let us
look at the evidence and try to
understand decision i did
quote the other time that the process
him sometimes would would
would visit his wives in one night
and at one point the prophet had nine or
eleven wives
at the same time okay so that means that
was pretty
intense masha'allah you know uh uh you
know
timing and the sahaba report the process
had the strengths of tens of men like
almost like up to 100 men subhanallah
like the sexual strength and the
strength right
so the process was if anyone was
alpha the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
the best creation of allah he was the
man if there was
any man out there he was the man
all right no if ands and buts about it
so it's important why are we discussing
these issues
i think and we want to give disclaimers
if you're not comfortable with this
discussion and what we're talking i
think
what is it they just turn off or what
let's just go see their kids they should
turn off i just also wanted to slip
something in that
um surah was not revealed at the time i
believe that he had 11 wives because
again a lot of people like how did he
have
11 wives if you could only have four
guys the quran wasn't revealed at once
right it came in you know different
times but anyway that ruling is for the
believers as allah says in the quran the
prophet
sallam actually was exempted from that
and allah says so there's no kharaj or
there's no difficulty
upon you so the prophet was he had
specific things that he was supposed to
do such as
he would pray qiyam every night this was
fard upon him and some of the scholars
say for us it's not
but it's must for him he would fast also
24 hours
continuously he wouldn't break as fast
that's not allowed for us we have to
break our fast
so there's certain specific things that
are allowed and
actually imposed upon the prophet sallam
that are not upon
um us for example we live inheritance he
doesn't
right stuff like that there's certain
things that only apply to him
and don't apply to us so yeah
alhamdulillah so
i guess the disclaimer is that
definitely some people might not feel
comfortable with this
you say kids had but some adults also
sometimes they feel like you know i
don't want to listen to this this is too
bad or whatever we try not to be vulgar
we're trying to be quite academic and
give
our evidence for whatever we say but
today i think
because we're going to get into the
issue of oral sex that's where we're
left off
last time we talked about oral sex and
we're going to get a little into
positions and all that
and obviously if people are not
comfortable and they don't want to
they want to just kind of be ignorant
about this
that's fine as a positive islamic
psychology counselor
and having been practicing for the past
17 years in counseling
i could say that most of the
problems that have come when it comes to
marriage i think i've said this many
times is
a number one incompatibility from a
religious point of view right like
people are just not compatible
uh intimacy okay the issue of intimacy
and
being incompatible when it comes to
intimacy and
communication other than that like
finances
disagreements family work this
that all those things can be solved if
let's say even let's say we would expect
that two people are compatible in
in islam right so they get married and
we both are practicing alhamdulillah so
let's put that on the side let's say
for the sake of argument if
you have good intimacy
and good communication i believe
personally based on
the clients that i deal with in the
cases that you can pretty much solve any
problem
you can pretty much go through your life
and
deal with any challenges but if you
don't have good intimacy
and good communication i think then the
marriage is pretty much
bound to fail or people stay in the
marriage
for the sake of a b c d e but they
suffer
they actually suffer and many times they
end up
destroying each other's lives and just
being very toxic for each other
just for to keep up appearances within
the family or the culture
and so on and so forth so honestly i
really love coming on your podcast
because it's it is the
the realest podcast in the dunya it's
like we're talking about like
real stuff and it's as polite as
possible but
we're not shying away and we're trying
to educate the people with the objective
of hopefully inshallah
some of the knowledge that they get from
this it can save their marriage
why not you know why not
and honestly bro i've had a lot of
messages coming through and saying
alhamdulillah that the things that you
guys been saying
it's really helping and it's changed my
life it's changed my marriage
and a lot of times it is sisters who are
you know sending these messages saying
you know what
first we hated what you guys were saying
or we didn't like this blah blah blah
but after listening for some time and
introspecting and analyzing what's going
on in our lives
you know it's right so hopefully this
will be beneficial
yeah so anyone that's a kid anyone
that's a little sensitive about these
topics
anyone that doesn't want to have a good
sex life please just get off the video
right now
you do realize you could just leave a
disclaimer like
right before the video i like to engage
with the audience
i think you guys do put the disclaimer
there on right sometimes sometimes
okay so last time we said um we were
building towards the actual intimacy act
what happens you know on the night some
of the mistakes some of the you know
people rushing into things
and we talked a lot about uh foreplay
and how important foreplay is
now when it comes to foreplay we said
that there's there should be a rule
that's established
and it's either a ratio it's either two
to one or three to one
uh for the you know the woman to climax
before
the man and we said that even i think it
was rami that said it right
you know he's not here but he said if
the woman can climax before you actually
penetrate or engage in intercourse that
is a
great achievement because it reduces a
lot of the pressure
so guys have performance anxiety and
pressure
so we have two problems if you are
overly stimulated
you will ejaculate very fast and that is
called premature ejaculation
sometimes it can be poi or porn induced
pio sorry
porn induced premature ejaculation
and it can also be erectile dysfunction
or what's called performance
so i think one is easier than the other
one the
the uh the premature ejaculation is
easier to deal with
than not being able to be erect or
having you know erectile dysfunction
so definitely there's a lot of stress
because we're the performance
we're the ones that have to actually
deliver we're the ones that have to be
erect we're the ones that have to do
with the
work pretty much so definitely if we're
not
if we're not up to it then it's going to
be a problem and this is where you again
see that the man is
men are the providers and i've always
said that
that provider of not only food and
clothes and but you know also passion
love mercy uh and yes
uh pleasure as well i mean you are a
provider of pleasure you know
it's important for that to be understood
and men should take that as a
as an honor and as a responsibility
like if you please you're a woman you
should be
like happy with yourself and it should
it increases your your your confidence
you know what i mean
and if you don't what i've seen in some
of my clients that report
that they really have low self-esteem
and it just snowballs
and they just kind of crawl up into this
like little ball and they just
get so embarrassed and they don't want
to talk and they just
move apart from their wife and they
don't want to discuss it because it's
embarrassing
so it's very simple inshallah the
men can engage in foreplay with a
mindset that this is what i'm doing now
let it obviously the first night is
going to be a bit more calculated
because if you just let things go you
might go as well very fast
so you have to be a bit careful with
that
but don't sit there and calculate okay
number one number two like have a list
of what you're gonna do you know because
it's gonna be very unnatural
and let it be quite organic but at the
same time
be mindful of yourself and of your body
how your body reacts if you're getting a
bit
too aroused slow down take it easy take
a breath
and relax right because if you're not
then obviously you might
finish the work before the work even
starts
so so so um
it's important to to have the woman
climax before you and we talked about
how you can do that you know women love
kissing
talking using different words you know
we called it you know
dirty talking but you know we have to be
careful with that as well but you know
dirty talking
and you know uh stimulation of the
of the genitalia of the vagina and
problem is a lot of men also don't know
the biology of the woman i'm not sure
if they didn't go through anatomy class
or whatever
but they don't know the biology of the
woman and the biology of the woman is
very advanced
okay she has a lot of pleasure points
yet
they are you know specific and you need
to know
exactly where to touch so a lot of men
have no clue
where the woman's pleasure points are
hence he cannot
stimulate her properly he thinks he's
doing it
but he's not and so
you know the clitoris is a very
important and very sensitive part and it
is
a super center of pleasure
most women report if you look at the
statistics to orgasm
clitorally or only from the from the
clitoris
okay a lot of guys don't know that so
if that is stimulated and the person
knows exactly where it is and how to
touch it
then of course the woman will be led to
orgasm quite quickly actually it goes
quite fast
and once she's achieved orgasm and she
has climaxed then obviously she has a
certain
respect for it because you've done the
job you know what i mean but also the
pressure is lifted off
the guy like he's now oh i've done my
job
now i can relax now you can move on
towards
intercourse another good thing as we
said the last time that
women are in general multi-orgasmic so
they
oscillate within the orgasmic plate
and they're still in the zone even after
one orgasm
and the moisture is quite intense when
she's orgasm so now
actually supanola like intercourse is
much easier
once she has uh you know once she is
more moist and there's that you know uh
a discharge
that comes out yeah so now it's easier
what did you say i said fluids bro
fluids yeah fluids that's right
screaming yeah yeah exactly so
uh fluids and it's easier to penetrate
once uh the fluids come out and
because what happens is if see that's
that's how you know whether a female is
kind of turned on or not or she's ready
or not
the moisture like the man he usually
gets erect
if he's ready the woman gets moist as
well as the clitoris gets very hard
and uh the nipples of the breast they
get hard those are some of those
actually increases in size too yes it
increases the size because what happens
the clitoris is pretty much a lot of
people don't know that but it's the same
material as the penis
okay it's pretty much okay so it's like
you can say like a small
you know why are you laughing on her
yeah so so
bro i'm literally studying an embryology
like everything i know this
i know of the male projects into a penis
exactly
that that's when the differentiation of
the gender happens right
so yes exactly so basically yeah the
blood flows through that
to that area and that's what increases
in size and
and and it becomes hard same like for
the male right
so now it's you know it's ready for
basically intercourse but what i'm
trying to say again the pressure is
off the guy okay the pressure is off the
man now
uh he can you know take it easy even
psychologically he's going to feel
confident it's like you scored you know
and when you score a goal right
in the match you feel more confident
feel more excited
in a good sense so he's going to be able
to
relax better and inshallah enjoy
intimacy
even better before obviously entering
there's another point that we said we're
going to discuss and that is that of
oral sex now i know that we've kind of
focused a lot on the men
right of what the men supposed to do so
women also have a
part to play here but because they're
the receiver
i mean you can say that in general for a
beginner
guy if the woman doesn't know too much
she doesn't really need to know that
much for a more advanced male who has
some requirements now and has had some
experience then he can
start assessing whether a woman knows
what she's doing or doesn't
and that can make the difference no
doubt but in general for a virgin or a
beginner
he's pretty much okay with you know
whatever he gets the woman is there as a
recipient of you know intercourse and
he's going to be quite
quite satisfied so oral sex
now
the issue of oral sex is something
that's been debated among the scholars
and there is no clear
cut proof to say haram or halal
let's go okay so
so that's where you have to take in
the the the approach but the prophet
salallahu mentioned
one thing only that was impermissible
when it comes to intercourse
okay and that is anal intercourse
okay via the anus and
allah subhana the prophet told us that
allah will not look on a man who
approaches his woman
in the okay in the anus
all right so based on that for example
the scholars bro i'm just gonna pause
you real quick we had a patreon question
who asked the same question
he he asked what about putting other
stuff in there
okay well we'll uh we can address that
inshallah so
yeah so um so the chafees
they you know they have uh you know the
ruling on this
you know many of them say it is
permissible i remember
uh you know one of my teachers saying
that he was in a
in a meeting with some of the sheikhs
and one of the students of knowledge
asked
kind of like in a shy way uh excuse me
my uncle you know he was egyptian
he said can we like
you know lick it like is it permissible
so the sheikh
he said in the verse you say lick the
booty oh
no no no lick the [ __ ] oh okay
all right go ahead i'm still i'm still
on the top
all right
okay so i guess the scholar he said a
very strong arabic term he says
eat it my son eat it
please don't lick it he said eat it but
it was like it was like
kind like kulia mikul like eat my son
eat you know
so and he was like in a gathering you
know but okay so
putting all jokes aside i know some
people might get upset because this but
yes
um oral sex is
allowed according to many of the
scholars they give the
reasoning that the process specified
anal sex not being allowed
and if he specified something he would
have specified other stuff as well
all right however that was not specified
and by default yes the arabs did have
knowledge of this because
i don't want to say which sahaba maybe
some i don't know maybe i can see i mean
when someone came to him and it was
they were just uh having some i think it
was a treaty of herder
and uh one of the the non-muslims came
to him and he was a bit
arrogant so he basically said to him
uh go and suck on a lot
right so it was like he kind of insulted
him right so you can tell that the arabs
had knowledge of
of oral sex and what it was and so on
right
and that is something that is that needs
to be understood some people say no this
was for
and this is something that the
westerners invented and so on it's not
uh oral sex is something important
i believe uh based on what the scholars
that i spoke to and i asked and
discussed some say it's not i believe
it's more from a cultural
you know holding back but what needs to
be understood
again in terms of the reality of the
21st century if
something is not haram and you are
making upon
yourself haram okay so allah says in
surat
to the prophet saws
why do you make something haram upon
yourself that allah has made halal
so by default what we need to understand
the sharia says few things
by default acts of worship are
all haram unless given an evidence
okay so you cannot pray five rakaas for
maghreb
or you cannot do a like a head spin or
windmill
break dancing move and make zikr you
know and say that this is worship
because there's no evidence for that but
the opposite is in a lot and dealings
with people
including sex that everything is halal
unless proven haram okay this
is the this is the rule in sharia needs
to be understood
because a lot of people out of their own
goodwill like they're trying to be
you know clean and nice and religious
and so on but they're going to make
things that are
permissible or in the least sense
mubarak which are not specified just
you know just there permissible
they're going to make themselves what
happens
in the context of our discussion many
women report that they've never
orgasmed man okay i just received a
question yesterday
and basically was saying and yes these
questions come in you have to understand
the ummah is in dire need for someone to
answer these questions
and scholars have answered some of these
questions but i'm not sure why we're
having this
holier than the prophet saws syndrome in
the west where we're surrounded by
a hypersexualized society yet the
muslims are trying to
i don't know it's like we never think
about these things we do it's it's
inside of our minds every single day
and the ummah is wandering and
so the question was that when i
masturbate i can orgasm but when i have
sex with my husband i cannot
all right so it's quite alarming because
what happens why does a woman
you know is able to do that because when
she masturbates she stimulates her own
uh clitoris and genitalia and she knows
exactly there's a connect between you
know when like if i ask you scratch my
back
and i'm like no no not there like here
you know there because
i know exactly where it's itching and
you're trying to get it you know because
you're not connected to
you know to me but for me if i'm i'm
going to know exactly where to scratch
myself
because there's a connection there's a
link between my brain
and the stimuli that's coming
specifically i can touch
exactly where i want to so indeed a
woman will know exactly where to touch
herself
and how and there's a connection between
the feeling and to increase the
intensity or lower it or whatever
so definitely she knows how to pleasure
herself not to mention that many women
of course in men but specifically we're
talking about women do
grow up masturbating and so on this is
just a reality man as much as people
want to deny it this is just the
reality um there was a study that i
looked at recently
and they're trying to find some
differences in people masturbate
pornography and dawn and they said we
couldn't find like
there's no like there's people
everyone's watching it now like there's
no
it's very difficult to find statistics
to make a differentiation so
if oral sex is not understood
so yes then women will go unsatisfied if
women go unsatisfied then there's a
problem
because if you understand the biology
psychology the woman
it's quite different than that of the
men it's like a
psycho it's very very difficult for a
woman
when she's not pleased a guy also he has
an interesting um manifestation of not
being pleased but for a woman
you know you can almost see when the
when you're dealing with females in a
workplace or outside if she's not being
satisfied if she's got
like issues that if it's stuck pretty
much you know like she'll just
you'll feel it you're just simple
yeah these are two things you're gonna
see when she is uh
pmsing okay and you're gonna feel when
she hasn't been pleased
like she's gonna she's gonna let it out
on you you know so you better watch out
not everyone i know sisters you're not
like that i know you're the exception
but
yeah a lot of women will do that
and it is important to understand so if
the woman can climax herself
and it's very problematic she's married
and does that and yes many women report
that they have sex
and once intimacy is done between her
and her husband the husband kind of
rolls around to the other side
and says oh honey that was great was
that good for you
okay yes it was good and she'll go to
the bathroom and finish herself
because he did not finish her okay she
did not have
and that's quite shameful and if a man
doesn't know and we're going to talk
also about faking orgasm
if a man doesn't know that his whether
he's
his wife climax or not it's another
problem it's another shame i would say
you should be able to understand whether
your
wife climaxes or not you should care you
don't love that woman you have no
passion for her
you don't care about her her well-being
if you don't
know and don't care to know whether
she's been pleased
or not okay so women will please
themselves
okay they'll go to the bathroom one of
the sisters say that i just roll around
and he's already asleep and i just
finished myself because
i'm gonna go crazy tomorrow when i go
out i'm going to take care of my
children
i'm going to start beating them i'm
going to have super stress on myself
because it's a bunch of hormones that
are boiling inside of me
release orgasm for a woman is a reset
it's a reset button okay the more
orgasms the more reset it's like
clearing out the cache on a computer or
on a phone you know what i mean it's not
gonna function properly unless you clear
the cache
okay you gotta clear that cache man you
gotta clear
the storage you gotta clear you know to
release the memory so that the computer
works optimally
if so she said i'm gonna i'm gonna take
it on my kids tomorrow i'm gonna be like
super psycho you know it's gonna be felt
and i need to release myself
not to mention that of course
subhanallah the way
the society is targeting females to
destroy them
with the amount of toys that they
provided for them so many women are
using vibrators and all kinds of
you know dildos and all these things you
know and if you look at some of the
stuff it's like
crazy man like what have these people
been thinking about right
so if a woman starts using these things
it have super
vibration with different speeds and
different powers and all that
of course she's gonna get used to this
super sizes you can take it in all
different sizes if you want you know
what i mean
plugs and this and that then of course
she will condition herself to react to
that
and her husband miss kenya you know
who knows what's going on there he's not
going to be able to please her
he's not going to be able to please her
so
i don't know what do you guys think
about that like i think guys i need to
take t3 on merch coming soon we're going
to have t-shirts saying clear the cash
we have to ask these exactly no matter
how many reminders they just don't get
the message bro
yeah and you know and then they yeah go
ahead
i know i was gonna i was gonna say that
uh
women need to clear the cash but men
need to clear the cash like
multiple times a day multiple times
that's true
that is true that is true no doubt about
it but
subhanallah so that's where oral sex is
very important
because if the guy knows how to do it
and he knows
where to touch and how it is then of
course
uh he will be able to please her and
he'll be able to make her orgasm
then again as i said they can go into
intercourse and maybe
give her another orgasm or two and man
you can see the respect and the
difference in behavior total
difference in behavior man you know what
i mean
so you know guys come and say i don't
know why my wife don't respect me
i don't know why she's being you know
mean to me
you know i don't know like her period
already passed and i don't understand
what's wrong with her i'm like bro come
on man like
did you please her did you do you know
do things that were you supposed to
well i don't know like yeah i think so
i'm like you think so or do you know so
yeah he's like well i i you know she
says it's good
but she's always gonna start
women in general they won't tell you
that it's not good because they don't
want to hurt you
they don't want to lose you they don't
want to
many things right so they kind of take
the low end of the
you know the stick and they just kind of
go with it and as i said
some will be satisfying themselves and
it's sad
this is another thing with the lgbt and
the feminism they think men and women
are equal
nah women are more agreeable by nature
men are more disagreeable
this is also why statistically men go
further in careers but again that's a
different story the whole point i'm
trying to bring at home
is men are more disagreeable there's
nothing wrong with that
but because of that women usually don't
call things out
just to make the marriage work just to
not cause turmoil
and it's not our fault usually guys if
your woman's not sexually satisfied
it's your fault 100 it's not the woman's
fault
unless she's just 100 like into
sex not into sex what is that uh asexual
like she just doesn't even have
that's an anomaly right it is yeah yeah
i mean women are subhan allah if you
think about it
okay the amount of pleasure points that
they have
uh is just amazing you know what i mean
it's amazing if you study the anatomy of
the woman
she can orgasm from just her mind man
just from here you know just talk to her
in a certain way and just touch a little
bit and she like
you know she's done you know of course
the clitoris
the the labia the vagina
the g-spot the internal cervical orgasm
subhanallah super orgasm
multiple orgasm the nipples
just kissing and touching different
positions
i mean the guy is like one
pretty much pretty much there's a little
bit of variation we can discuss that
not men are not that simplistic but
compared to women
right women have i would say
an advantage when it comes to sex
you know what i mean like imagine some
women can have five six
up to ten orgasms in one sitting man
it's not a joke some people think no it
doesn't happen you're watching no
look at the studies look at the science
behind it
right so it is amazing she's basically
like a pleasure you know
uh house and there's there's a reason
for that you know and she's happy man
that's why if she's happy trust me
that's where in general the marriage
will be
happening allah thought about everything
perfectly bro you're right because
if it wasn't pleasing for a woman they
would there will be no incentive to have
sex
and then there will be no ummah there
would be no next generation
the prophet he described the woman
uh that is pleasing to a man and he said
the one that is
fertile and loving but the words that
are used is like
and she's intimate you know what i mean
she's a
a woman who procreates and who's
intimate and who's fertile
you know what i mean so definitely
that's attractive to men especially
right if a woman
is in pleasure or is pleased
that actually attracts a man you know
what i mean when a man
feels that man i can please my wife and
she's pleased and she's attracted to me
and she wants it
like it makes you feel like whoa you
know wow it's like really really good it
gives you confidence and strength
and you want to do it more as well so
you're kind of like stimulating each
other
right as opposed to sorry like having
intimacy every two weeks
as some people report every month or you
know i've had a client recently
like in two years they haven't had
intimacy you know what i mean
it's quite sad right it's quite sad and
then they ask they want
i don't know why there's this pressure
amongst us and these fights and these
arguments
and so on well because you're not able
to come
together and to be intimate to love each
other to share these emotions
and these beautiful moments so that is
extremely
important so yes i think the men need to
be
taught a little bit of anatomy and they
need to understand what is oral sex
i know guys usually like to receive it
because it's something you know they
really
feels like it gives them you know
domination and it's like you know
something big for men when it comes to
oral sex
and yes indeed a lot of women maybe also
don't know how to do that
uh and it's but but i don't think it's
that important for men i think for the
man it's just a psychological thing like
they just like to see it and to receive
it
but it's not necessarily the most
satisfying things i think
for men it's more of the intercourse
that matters right they want
actual you know intercourse but for the
woman as i said
because most women are only able to
climax
a clitoral orgasm that is very important
for the guy
to be able to understand how to do it
and how to please his wife that way
and as i said there's multiple things
like alhamdulillah
allah has given us hands so we can use
the hands you know the woman likes to be
touched like it's just don't just put
your mouth there and just you know think
you're
no you have to use you know many things
they can be
fingering at the same time while you
know doing oral sex
and stimulation which helps the woman um
you know to come or to climax even
better
the woman has an internal part that is a
rough part
and it's a projection small projection
it's about
two inches inside the vagina towards the
pubic bone right and that is the uh the
g-spot what's called the g-spot and
basically the man just has to stimulate
it kind of like in a come here
uh you know movement right like kind of
like using your finger just saying come
here
um that basic yeah so it's kind of like
you know come here
and it is come here and basically it's
just about two inches
inside now for those men who have i do
receive a lot of questions about like
size you know the size matter and this
and that and blah blah blah
and you know all these a lot of guys you
know will like send me i'm this much or
i'm that much is that good i'm about to
get married
i'm just like okay there is a you're not
gonna rate sizes
we got five minutes in this episode left
but uh is one inch enough
what is your fault no it has to be at
least
has to be at least three inches you know
micro penis is actually a medical
condition
it is a medical condition that's male 1
yeah but but now now that now there are
uh there are
surgical interventions subhanallah you
know women can have breast implants they
can have reduction of the labia they can
have this they can have
uh you know uh a circumcision the
clitoris they can have so many things
but now for men finally they're coming
up with some
there's a surgery that that's perceived
i forget it was for the labia or hymen
yes but if it's loose they can basically
get it tighter
they can tighten yes indeed they can yes
bro this is the gel bro
so the women can they have some you know
all kinds of options uh men are
still you know suffering but uh so
so going back to that yeah so to the
size and all that i
for the woman uh what many need to
understand
in general the average penis size around
the world
is about 5.5 inches okay or
five inches erect okay that's the
average okay anything above that is
above average so if anyone's six six
point five seven
whatever this is okay the is above the
average you go into the
uh 90th percentile and so on
but uh so but if you understand
the the anatomy of the woman i mean men
need to relax
sometimes they get very you know worried
about their size and this and that and
for the woman when it comes to the size
is more here you know
like it's an issue of the psychology
that a man you know like having muscles
having broad shoulders a man being
bigger
it's something that is aesthetically and
psychologically pleasing for a woman
when her husband is has a
strong masculine frame what we call
and part of a strong masculine frame of
course it
is his uh his penis right that he should
basically be strong with that but it's
as i said it's more in the mind now
a lot of men don't know this but a lot
of women cannot
cannot entertain a larger sized male
cannot
they hurt it's painful they don't enjoy
it
okay especially when they lose their
virginity and
even throughout unless just had quite a
few kids or unless she's really gone you
know uh
a-hole you know i mean you know she's
gone like done
uh that's a different story but i'm
talking about your average
yeah your average woman good woman who
marries and this and that
they cannot cannot take something what
people
think what pornography shows is some
huge you know this and that
no they cannot unless those women those
women in porn take it because they're
used to taking it
yeah them and you know they really
stretch themselves out but a regular
woman mashallah who's you know even if
she
has one two partners like she's married
maybe her husband passed away she
married again or whatever divorce
had a few kids even after a few kids
finally women again allah has blessed
them to
to their their body adapts again if they
take care of themselves
and so on their body readjusts you know
so
a lot of women report pain and hurt and
it's not pleasurable
what so ever right so
guys need to get this thing out of their
mind that oh i have to be this and that
or if i'm too small or
this you know like don't set stop
sending you know sizes and you know
asking us to to to know what i mean
what's your size and whether it's good
or not
just be comfortable be you know it's
it's really
having the skill that's more important
all right that that is then just to
think about you have to be like
you know this huge size or whatever okay
but at the same time
obviously you cannot be a micro you know
penis as you said if that is the case
then a man has to go to the doctor
and seek some professional help and
there are now some
procedures that can help inshallah to to
take care of that guys do consult a
physician none of this is medical advice
yes do you want to wrap up the
other fatwas pertaining to the back side
okay so when it comes to the anus there
is
small slight difference of opinion
whether you can stimulate it with your
finger or with something
okay some people say you can touch it
and stimulate it and biologically
speaking there are a lot of nerve
endings there
that are very very pleasurable for the
woman hence yes
a lot of non-muslim women they do engage
in anal intercourse because they find it
pleasurable
but allah italian is you know restricted
that and did not allow that i believe
it's not correct
but as some of the scholars said that
just touching it or touching it with
something is permissible if it's just
for pleasure
and so on and you know it's it's but but
again it can lead to like if you're
there and you're taking pleasure from
that
you're kind of like you know playing
with fire you know what i mean because
it's very easy to slip yeah it's very
easy to
to slip there right so some some have
said that you know just touching it just
you know it's it's permissible as for
inserting things in it i wouldn't
i wouldn't again recommend okay because
it would
cause someone to i think fall and sleep
one last uh thing for this episode um
any rulings on
menstrual okay so menstrual
uh it is not permissible to have
intercourse some have asked what about
if you have like
uh a condom on or protection
it's still not permissible okay however
you can stimulate the woman on top of
her you know
pants or panties or something like that
just like touch the clitoris
and it's very pleasurable because a lot
of moisture and a woman orgasms very
easily when she's on her period
and the processor used to fondle and
touch aisha radiola
when she was on her menstrual cycle and
she would be just wearing something
like some kind of you know undergarment
and he would be intimate in that case
and other stuff
as well it's allowed what's called like
dry sex you can
rub and hump and all that and even that
just even without penetrating
if let's say the penis is erect and the
woman is very you know obviously whether
she's wearing something just rubbing
against each other can be very very
pleasurable because it usually touches
the the clitoral part
and a woman can climb it's very very
easy and then the man can also climb
extra oral sex or through you know
a hand job or anything like that or just
humping from the back or something you
can hump the back
and a man will still be able to climb so
this is
not correct in islam people believe that
on when the more you know seven days i'm
off you know what i mean like there's no
intimacy no
because finally like the men and women
kind of drift apart you know you have to
be intimate
you have to some of the religions like
the jews and they used to believe that
it's very dirty they would stay away
from their wives no the protestant was
intimate with his wives
and he was close to him there was love
and passion and you know an attachment
even during the period but
no intercourse and even if people try to
rationalize it well what if i'm wearing
a condom no it's it's very clear that
just no
intercourse during this period
it's pretty sufficient one more last
thing
intimacy during ramadan and i think that
should be it for the photos
okay intimacy ramadan yes
i don't know you got any thoughts i
wanted to like say two things but i'm
gonna let
gabriel finish because he's gonna grow
up
yeah intimacy during ramadan guys that's
permissible after maghrib
maghrib till fajr man if you want to
break your fast and then go
go to fajr you know just make sure you
eat a bit of food and whatever you want
to do man you know so it's
as the prophet sallam said as allah says
it has been made permissible to you the
nights of the fasting okay
you are a clothing or a protection for
them they are a protection
for you you know so alhamdulillah it's
it is encouraged some people think that
oh it's going to take me away from my
bad
for my worship we are not better than
the prophets salallahu i keep repeating
this
we need to break these stereotypes and
these taboos
that we somehow are going to go away
from allah if we're intimate with our
wives
because it's ramadan no allah is that's
why
allah made the mourning to be fasted so
in the morning no intercourse no nothing
and then at night you can eat everything
that's impermissible during the fasting
is permissible at night
so you know it's all good
that should be it for me i know you got
like two wish minutes
any questions yeah i was just gonna say
that
um
like lives made it very easy for both
the man and the woman
because if a woman is in a marriage
with a man who let's say he's uh
he doesn't have barakah in that
department that's all right
because the woman can actually perform
exercises
very simple exercises known as kegels
if a woman perform kegels she will
actually
become tighter therefore
even a male that's not of even average
proportions will be more than enough for
her
yeah and yeah and for the male
look look how beautiful this is and
there are
certain exercises kegels
that'll help you in terms of like being
able to hold a
dry orgasm which we didn't actually
speak about
but that's all right next episode yeah
next episode inshallah but there are
other exercises like
joking um reverse joking
uh clamping and stuff like that now of
course
everything has its risk but then again
you know you go walking outside that has
its risk
so it's like if if a guy were to decide
to do this
he would have to understand all the
risks that are involved but like
there's been men that have gained like
two inches two and a half inches doing
this and it's all natural
you know so it and these are things to
like take into consideration
knowing how like look allah has blessed
you with all that you have
and even if for some reason you are not
content with what you have allah has now
given you a way like look if you
really want a little bit more or you
want to change this little bit right
here
here i provided this for you now go
ahead and get to work
that's right i think that's i think
that's beautiful beautiful
hi guys if you made it this far
comment hashtag please her
and scare the cash clear the cat clear
the cash
clear the cash as well hashtag clear the
cash and please her
now next episode we will be going more
into the
actual act itself marriage night stuff
like that inshallah
there's nothing else from you guys then
thank you for watching
for tuning in until next time salaam
alaikum
salaam if
both of them have responsibilities or
roles
it is irrational to expect or demand
that they fulfill something which allah
himself is not made obligatory
this whole thing about uh i still want
him to do a little bit of
dishes or just do a little bit of the
choice
if he does it he does it if he doesn't
he doesn't but you cannot
expect that similarly if a woman wants
to work
cool you know women can work i'm not
against that she wants to go to school
cool
but you cannot expect her to make money
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um